a study undertaken this year shows that
the persecution and mass murder of
Christians around the world is worse
today than at any time in history and
Western governments are failing not only
to stop it but even to acknowledge it
father George Rutter has just
inaugurated the first shrine in the
world dedicated to persecuted Christians
at his church which is the same church
where I weds whittlin ELISA just a month
ago the church of st. Michael in Hell's
Kitchen we will discuss the totally
silenced Christians plight then the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this is gonna be very politically
incorrect show not politically correct
it is a really strange thing right now
this study even I didn't realize it and
I've been kind of tuned into these
issues of Christian persecution in the
Middle East and around the world it's
right now Christians in the world are
the most persecuted faith group that
there is you wouldn't know that if you
talk to people in America or in Europe
they always talk about Islamophobia
which Andrew Clavin I believe once
defined as the irrational fear of having
your head cut off that's not politically
correct but that's all you hear about
you don't hear about the Christians it's
silence we're talking about how we need
to bring Muslim migrants of all we have
to do is bring the Muslim migrants over
we bring hardly any Christian refugees
over and the Christian refugees are the
ones who are being utterly decimated by
Muslim militants throughout the Middle
East and elsewhere according to this
study by aid to the church in need they
examined Christians in China Egypt
Eritrea India Iran Iraq Nigeria North
Korea Pakistan Saudi Arabia Sudan Syria
and Turkey only Saudi Arabia has not
gotten significantly worse for
Christians over the last few years and
that's only because it can't really get
much worse you know it's like they're
it's not you know a thriving metropolis
of Christians the Christians have been
almost entirely wiped out of Iraq and
Syria we know we had G somehow on the
show the North Korean defector just a
week or two ago
and he talked about how if you were said
to be a Christian in North Korea you
will be executed publicly and on the
spot no questions asked
gun pulled out shoot you right in the
head you know this is a weird thing and
especially in the United States and in
Europe I think we have this sense now
especially lefties here have this sense
that Oh a rock and Syria those are those
are for Muslim people that's not the
Christians aren't supposed to be there
those aren't for Christian people but of
course Syria was a the home of
Christianity for so long and all of not
all of them but many of the early popes
came out of syria peter is from
Bethsaida Paul had his conversion he
they you know we had the scales over his
eyes knocked off his knocked off his
horse on the road to Damascus or knocked
Office as he's going up to Damascus
that's not in that's not in you know
Rome that's not in tours that's not in
England that's in Syria but
we have this this idea that you know
that's for the Muslims that's for the
Muslim people all over the Middle East
and Africa the there was some Samaria q
shion's of Christians torture
crucifixion all of these things not
politically correct to say but that's
why we brought on my priest and good
friend father George Rutner father rut
ler is how do you even introduce this
guy a singular figure in my reversion to
Christianity he is the pastor of the
Church of st. Michael in New York he's
the author of I think 700,000 books at
this point he's a boxer he's a painter
he's a terrific painter he plays piano
plays violin he you know he's just a
true renaissance man I asked him one
time he was very kind to display my
political tome reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide in his
rectory in New York and father rut ler I
asked him I said how do you do all of
this how do you host TV shows and write
your columns all the time to write books
and do that and then and he looked at me
he said don't sleep it's fair enough
answer I have to take that advice he
stopped by to talk about the Christian
persecution and as excuse me as happens
with him the conversation wandered a bit
without further ado here is father
mother father mother thank you so much
for being here
delighted to do it father allure the
last time I saw you you were marrying me
off right well it was a wonderful day I
really really enjoyed it I estimate
roughly I've had about 800 weddings and
they each one is like like the first one
I there's a lot of work involved and
people don't realize that but it's a
great joy to me you know it was so
lovely and it was so I was so pleased
that you didn't that we did it at the
Church of st. Michael and I know some of
the viewers of the show I've seen photos
that I've been posting of it and it
occurs to me right before I got married
I'm all nervous I'm standing in the
rectory I actually saw this shrine the
first shrine in the world dedicated to
the persecution of Christians and it it
shocks me in two ways one
that there are so many persecuted
Christians you know and that nobody is
really talking about this and the other
that it's the first shrine in the world
dedicated to them how did how did it
come about and why is nobody caring
about the persecuted Christians or first
of all I have a good friend and priest
from England although he is actually a
priest working and coordinated as we say
in Canada on it is he's and inscribed in
a diocese in in Vermont but he's been on
leave now to go and work with the
Christian Emma grace in in Iraq he works
out of England but he's back and forth
to Iraqi is taking some some doctor
documentary films travel is stunning the
historic centralized looks like
Hiroshima after the bomb we don't see
much of that so he is raising
consciousness he he's organized a group
called the Nazarene org in a as a en and
they use the letter n the Arabic letter
the Noom it's called Newman Arabic
alphabet Nazarene because the Muslim
countries will not allow the use of the
word Christian so they they call
Christians Nazarenes Jesus was Nazareth
and these little badges is to raise
consciousness it's sort of like you know
the a lot of people in the Second World
War
deliberately wore yellow stars to show
their empathy for the persecuted direct
power Jews and the icon we're talking
about was done by an Iraqi from the area
of our Deen which are in Arabic means or
Aramaic they speak Aramaic which was the
language our Lord spoke means Eden
his house and their property and
everything were confiscated by the ISIS
so here to take his family in exile to
Lebanon and the icon shows the the
Virgin Mary dressed as an Iraqi bride
the second question is why has there
been such little publicity well first of
all is politically incorrect because the
residence is a Western culture on the
whole I think is very threatened by
Islam doesn't understand Islam a lot of
people I think of a lot of people of
naive left-wing sympathies are following
replicating the same mistake that was
made in the 1930s by a lot of the
Western intelligentsia who thought well
mmm
Hitler is a kind of crackpot but at
least he's anti-bolshevik so the enemy
of my enemy is my friend
and so they looked the other way about
her towards the Nazi atrocities
Kristallnacht they thought that would
that led to the concentration cares we
have to remember that a lot a lot of the
Western media including the New York
Times ignored all the evidence on the
concentration camps there was a very
noble Polish Catholic layman professor
Yan Karski who will eventually went into
exile he documented the concentration
camps was going on he came to the West
he went to London they didn't want to
hear about it in Whitehall he went to
Washington he had an hour with Franklin
Roosevelt Franklin Roosevelt ignored him
polite but didn't want to hear this he
met with Felix Frankfurter who was the
only Jewish members the Supreme Court
who just was angry were he and he walked
around the room and said you know he
couldn't believe it and later on he said
I didn't call Koski a liar I just said
that I couldn't believe him
well that's what these people are doing
a lot of these people are doing today
because to admit what's going on is to
admit the with this long we're dealing
with something different from what
Western bourgeois minds think is
religion
you know we so often hear that these
extremists are unrepresentative of the
Quran well read the Quran it's right
there it's not the extremists it's the
more moderate Muslims god bless them who
want really to integrate into us in
society
we got virtues of judeo-christian
society there they're the they're the
eccentric militant Islam represents the
authentic interpretation of the Quran
and that's very politically incorrect to
say but it's a mm it's a fact and to
acknowledge that what's going on in the
Middle East where you have countries
with the Christian populations of
evaporating right in Bethlehem
everybody's probably the the population
the Christian population they're in the
birthplace of Christ vanishing people do
not want to admit it and I think it's
just like just as in the 1930s you had
people you know being giving the pass to
the now ZZZ because they thought that
they did Hitler and Stalin could fight
it out among between themselves where
they didn't we had there he had the
Ribbentrop pact which upset the leftists
in the West it's so today we have people
thinking that well yeah the bullroar
liberal progressives who are anti
judeo-christian civilization yeah they
wouldn't put it that way but they are
the way they wonder who this fragment
the whole judeo-christian moral
structure they'll say well alright Islam
these people are kind of nutty but
they'll bring down judeo-christian
society and I said well again the enemy
of my enemies of my friend but
as with letting giving a hit or a pass
you don't understand when you do that
what it is Phyllis you are unleashing on
the world of course that you know it's
interesting that you you mentioned that
this this long-standing conflict between
Islam and the West Hilaire Belloc the
great Catholic writer wrote about this
in the 1930s you said read a low right
now things are going alright
but within half a century or so Islam
may start rising up against the West
again and we're going to have to deal
with it and I saw there was a study by
aid to the church in need and the
McLaughlin and Associates which showed
that among American Catholics the
persecution of Christians in the Middle
East and elsewhere ranks the lowest
among their list of concerns and global
priorities ranking higher or poverty
which I believe will always be with us
it's written a book somewhere and a
climate change climate change is a
greater priority and I think it speaks
to what you're talking about
there has been an ideological
displacement or assault on
judeo-christian morality and Western
civilization and that ideological
assault is replacing it you saw Dianne
Feinstein grilling a judge Amy Kony
Barrett and she said you know I'm
worried because the dogma lives loudly
within you there does seem to be a real
battle here I you you saw this firsthand
you you're in New York City you've been
there you were an eyewitness to the
September 11th terrorist attacks you
were down there at the Trade Center has
the culture moved in any sort of better
direction in the country or are we just
sliding toward further decay no no I
don't I don't think I don't think it has
are you know the difference between the
theological virtue of Hope which is
trusting in God and the humanistic
quality of
optimism optimism is just wishing things
will be well hope means knowing things
will go well if we trust in God in a
long time yes I say to my friends you
know this our culture
is very decadent but as an historian I
would say we can hopefully say that
maybe in two or three hundred years
things will get better but but that's
unless you intend to live that long
that's not so much of a consolation I
belong to part Scottish I belong to some
Scottish societies of the Scottish tend
to be you some of them generalization a
little doer little surly yeah yeah but
the difference between a Scottish
pessimist and this cottage option is in
a Scottish pessimist would will say Oh
things couldn't be any worse than they
are now
and if Scots optimist says oh yes they
can
but I think your people are like they do
it like the the ostrich with his head in
this air and they're they don't want to
admit what's going on Europe is learning
you're visiting but the hard way I think
that's the heroic cultures where I think
of Poland yeah and and Hungary
perhaps Croatia some of the those those
countries that have suffered so vividly
all through history but most
dramatically in president they know what
they are dealing with others are
comfortable and the you know as a matter
of fact you know the statistics was of
the all the heads of the EU countries I
think all the heads of the UN countries
at least six of them are childless Wow
so you know we have demagogues and I
always I know that when politicians say
we're doing this for our children stop
it that's that's demagoguery but in
Europe it's worse because they don't
have any children to worry about
yeah we're just doing it for ourselves
they love a socialist economy because
it's their day they can pass the debt on
it because they have here they're their
own they don't have children inherit
that dad that's going to the burden is
going to be on the body politic so
can be labor the image of the decline
and fall wrong part the noble Roman
Republic was transformed and into the
Imperium
alright you had a noble Emperor's like
Augustus later are maybe constantly but
most of them you know they were they
were like Bill Clinton on a bad day and
and so what happened what happened they
didn't want they got soft they couldn't
fight and then you heard the gossip is
aghast vandals the Huns listened to
their names the Vandals and the Huns
that gives you a good doesn't sound
exactly the touch it's not exactly the
order of the Cincinnati and but they
didn't want to admit and the other
people were well-trained and they they
could find a soft spot and and they
moved in and I think that's the way we
are today or we have just you know when
you have a whole culture grow is it or
miss shaping this the younger culture
when you have their whole culture page
basically their their fondest memories
of Woodstock and now there are the
tenured professors and deans and
presidents the universities they've
misformed the whole generation so when
our election goes contrary to what they
thought it would be what they were
taught it would told it was going to be
in the bubble in which they live what
happens they have to go into psychiatric
treatment safe spaces and all that
that's like coloring books and puppies
yeah but when the Barbarian invades
there are no say that is a fearful
warning certainly and it is true I saw
this among my friends who were still in
graduate school in college and the
campuses erupted they were so shocked
and horrified when president from one
and there is this glimmer of light I
hope in so much as there has been
deregulation there has been
protection of religious freedom of
individual liberty and and there are all
of these judges this has been the great
fight all of last week are the judges
who are not only or textualist and
originalist and lean conservative but
dare I say they're all Catholic and this
did actually raise a question to me when
you look back at American history I
think it was Arthur Schlessinger said
that anti-catholicism is the deepest
bias in American history and yet the
leaders of the conservative movement
have all been Catholic it seems are
largely Catholic you had the Russell
Kirk you had a member of your own flock
Bill Buckley and you have all of the
judges on the Supreme Court why is that
why does Catholicism seem to play some
role in American conservatism well mmm
well because Catholicism is rooted in
pardon really technical language a
realist epistemology that is to say they
have concrete truths is there this
contradicts relativism subjectivism the
paramount definer of that philosophy was
Thomas Aquinas
and I've noticed that justice gorsh arch
and now the nominee Cavanaugh both went
to the same church with prep school now
I am NOT going to risk my life in
defense of the church let's go ahead my
great disagreements were fair not to
interrupt but you know the difference
between the Jesuits and Dominicans don't
you the difference of course is that
they were both Spanish orders they were
both founded to combat heresy
the Dominicans to combat the Alba
Jensen's the Jesuits to combat the
Protestants and when was the last time
you ever heard of an Albertan see
and bear in mind there's a good example
or talking about about culture ISM but
agreed about the Alba Jerseyans what
they were doing they would have
destroyed Western civilization people
put down their there
they were put down harshly but if they
handle didn't destroyed we wouldn't be
here today it's as simple as that it's
like you know if the holy roman if if
you didn't have andrea doria and one
Wroblewski and these curved grater tires
this is combating the Islamic a Charles
Martel even before that combating the
Islamic invasion if you're we would not
be here today but you know I think the
Jesuits a bit like the little girl with
the curl in the middle of her forehead
when she was good she was very very good
when she was bad she was horrid
well it's very very they're very very
good carrots but I don't know if I'm not
sure they're a dying breed or not a pot
there there is this respect for the four
classical Aristotelian toniest
reality and that's lost in a subjective
culture which is disintegrating it by
its own lack of thousands of important
so if you live in a subjective culture
when truth is whatever you want it to be
what happens you you know a boy can go
into a girls locker room and say that
he's a girl fine
why is why is this being promoted I I
have to say I I live in New York City I
see millions of people here
I live on 34th Street which is the
craziest Street in the universe I have
never encountered a transgendered maybe
there's so well cause better sized
that recognize it but why it's such a
minut percentage of the population why
is this being promoted why is this the
national debate yes simply because it's
another barb in judeo-christian the
judeo-christian moral structure the
retired head of psychiatry at Johns
Hopkins is not a witch doctor he has
said the telling a child a boy that he
could be a girl or is his child abuse
this is a scientific fact
in the same way abortion
is anti-scientific it denies the reality
of the humanity of the unruly human life
of the unborn but now I just mentioned
that Casey decision in Pennsylvania that
being free means being able to define
your own concept of livered liberty and
the meaning of the mystery of life yeah
that sounds like some cheap opera of
mystery of life and wonderful poet
Anthony Kennedy yeah yeah my beloved
friend
Justice Scalia really devastated that
justifies a mockery of it but now who
wrote those words Justice Kennedy who's
a Catholic so just because of our garlic
doesn't mean that they're going to be
heirs or they may be heirs but doesn't
mean that they continue to subscribe to
a realist philosophy of the moral order
I mean Edward Kennedy claimed to be a
Catholic go down the list in fact it's
almost an indictment of politicians to
say when they loudly profess that their
calves like there is something wrong
with them you have to wonder what's
really going on yeah so there's no great
consolation there we have an interesting
phenomenon now whereby a lot of the
evangelicals have been promoting is the
Catholic Norman nominees for this
Supreme Court because they say but
there's a common bond there
theologically their problem but there's
a common bond layer in their belief and
the integrity of Scripture defying
revelation an objective objective
morality but you have some you can't a
lot of Catholics who are Catholics the
name only the same thing we have our
abuser Jewish here in name only I mean
isn't mrs. Ginsburg oh yes Elena Kagan
yeah but I wouldn't like to have her
talk to the chief rabbi about her stance
are on on moral issues but it's also
interesting that the media narrow just
Merck recognizes that the Catholic
probably the last voice of this of
realism moral realism that's why it has
to be brought out here you don't you
don't hear people they'll say well why
are there so many Catholics on the
Supreme Court now is that what would
happen if somebody said why are there so
many Jews on the Supreme Court the use
of over-represented in terms of
percentage of population god bless them
when somebody says that I did as a
legitimately an odor of anti-semitism
there but there's the twist with Jew
calculate products whatever there should
not be a test of religion and the only
disappointment I had in that very nice
woman good woman parrot parrot Coney
Maron yeah judge Barrett Barrett she
should have just said - that lady sine
Stein yes
these the set of tricks of California
she should have just instead of trying
to defend herself today
I'm sorry but I am a constitutionalist
and I will not be a subject to that
religious test right right of course I
you know and tell you Father rudder I'll
have to let you go because I've taken up
too much of your time already but
hearing you say that it really makes me
think that the dogma lives loudly within
you it really makes me echo the Senate
tricks from California's sentiments I
don't know the best way to handle some
of these people is just to mock them we
have false prophet the Devils the Prince
of Lies and what withers him is to mock
him if we take him too seriously then we
give him strength but I'm told I am told
now that there are coffee cups oh let's
say the dogma lives with me that's a
good to get it on a t-shirt or something
you know it's I must say I always I
listen to your homilies when I'm not in
New York and I can't go to the Church of
st. Michael and people can listen to
them like a podcast which I recommend
that everybody
and they can get your columns your
weekly column from the Church of st.
Michael and in crisis magazine by my
last count you've written about 300
thousand books in your life is there any
new book coming out where can people
find more of your writing
well actually this summer I have five
coming out now for our other set if this
was not my idea a group of businessmen
gotta go and these are a collection of
my past four columns over the last 15 20
years and they're in a box that leather
barrel with silk ribbons and it and the
advertisement I read to my astonishment
celebrating the life and legacy of
Father rattler it sounded like an
obituary I'm glad to hear you're still
still walking around and talking the
only the only thing lacking was you know
in lieu of flowers please send we're
like yeah yeah and then Ignatius press
is bringing out a collection of yeah of
my essays but I'm a parish priest I'm
here in the part of Manhattan called
Hell's Kitchen which indicates something
of the culture so I I only write these
things obliquely my life prints today I
said well I've got I heard confessions
that's my that's that's my job but
through the wonderful gift now of
communications we can reach a lot of
people well I hope at some point I can
match your volume of output you know you
have five books coming out this summer I
had one book coming out in my entire
life and it didn't have any words in it
so maybe maybe I'll be able to to
amplify my output well really that the
the advantage of writing book without
words is very hard to be sued for
plagiarism I suppose for the wrong guy I
can tell you that I I thought I thought
about your own usually do an audio
version of that with music by John Cage
that'll be very nice perhaps you can you
can conduct the arrangement of 433 by
John Cage I did you know I I kid you not
there was actually a guy who wrote an
anti-trump blank book I said I use write
liberally and it was another blank book
called reasons to to respect Donald
Trump or something like that and he
threatened in the Washington Post to sue
me for plagiarism to which I told him I
stole nothing I promise you sir I stole
nothing father Rutter I have taken up
all of your time I'm sure there there
are many masses to say and confessions
to give on in Hell's Kitchen so I'll let
you go we'll have to have you back
because you are famous on this program I
I quote and I'll use the word borrow
really you know is it the word is steal
all of your insights regularly so we'll
have to bring you back to so that you
can give them directly
well hello to everybody out on the wrong
coast out in la-la land
father other thank you so much for being
here and we'll talk to you soon by phone
or I'll see you in New York all right
thank you all right we're gonna have to
bring father brother back because I
steal from him so regularly I so
regularly maybe I'll say borrow lines
from his columns and talking to him and
listening to him so I'll have to bring
him back and then you get the real thing
you don't need to go through me and
maybe I'll have him answer you know all
my mailbag questions are always Catholic
to some I'll bring them on instead of
you know this kind of poultry lay
Catholic giving you answers if you're on
Facebook and YouTube I'm sorry we have a
lot of mailbag to get to today and
they're not all Catholic some of them
are very important
urgent public policy questions but if
you're not on daily wire.com you can't
ask questions in the mailbag and you
can't keep watching you can only keep
listening go to daily wired.com why well
you get me you get the intro Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you to ask
questions in the mailbag you get to ask
questions in the conversation know that
matters this is the mark Duplass vintage
today that I'm sipping on the mark
Duplass 2018 it's really the wrong mmm
oh that's good it's a young wine it's a
new wine it's not hasn't it hasn't
really aged for a while but something
tells me it's going to age just fine go
get your daily wire leftist to your
stump we're gonna do a wacom we'll be
right back with the mailbag
alright let's get into the mailbag we
are as usual tight on time so we'll just
fly through the first question from
Garrett who do you prefer Thomas
Jefferson or Alexander Hamilton
Alexander Hamilton it's a simple
question I like them both I'm not
disparaging Thomas Jefferson he's great
were Americans because we have both
Alexander Hamilton Alexander Hamilton
and Thomas Jefferson but Hamilton's
better he's the better one he's got the
better story he's got the better
thoughts he was more important and I
love him he's great and and also you
know when was the last time Thomas
Jefferson got a popular glib and musical
made about him huh I don't know I don't
remember that from Kyle Michael what is
this Alexander Pope quote about nature
being art unknown today funny you should
ask
I do quote that a fair bit funny you
should ask about that quote that quote
and that the whole quote is nature is
all nature is but art unknown to the all
chance Direction which thou canst not
see such that in the logic of the
universe as it unfolds as there is
Providence around us things that we seem
think or coincidences might not be
coincidences or there there might be
more than coincidences and that I first
read that on the cover of the first rut
look I ever read which sort of
introduced me to the guy it was pivotal
in my reversion to Christianity from
vague atheism and vague agnosticism and
the funny thing about Pope is that his
is these great lines he has wonderful
little couplet couplets you know hope
springs eternal in the human breast this
sort of things but at the end of all of
his poems there's just like grave heresy
so he's a really good line by line and
then poem by poem don't believe as much
as as you would but that's a great great
line I use it all the time and I do
believe that that is certainly true
next question from tan dear Michael in
the current climate this might be a
brave thing to ask
and an even braver thing to answer but
here goes isn't abortion which is also a
natural selection type way to eliminate
liberals from our society I still feel
it's unequivocally murder and will
continue to fight for their innocent
lives but perhaps part of the left's
problem is that they're ok with killing
their progeny please just call me tan
Thanks ok tan
well alright so you're saying that it's
murder and then you're saying but isn't
that's not so bad is it I don't know to
you that you're gonna go out and murder
liberals are you gonna go and kill them
a one of the arguments that really
brought me over from supporting abortion
to being pro-life was from a bioethicist
I was having lunch with and I gave all
those stupid freakonomics arguments for
why abortions great and she said which
of these arguments is not an argument to
go kill ethnic minorities in the inner
cities who are young men yikes that's
tough so what do you think I mean yeah
there is a sort of irony that these
lefties who put all of their hope into
politics seem to be killing off their
progeny that but I know I don't think
that's something we should celebrate you
know for the left everything is about
politics it's their God it's the God
they worship we don't worship that God
hopefully we've got other things going
on so we don't want to kill them we
don't want to see them killed you know
hope springs eternal in the human breast
so where there's life there's hope and
we should try to bring them up and that
way we'll we'll have more conservatives
will be able to to convert them.i one
time governor mitch Daniels I was
talking to him and we asked this was in
2012 we said you know everything's
looking so bleak is the west over I mean
or how are we ever going to defeat the
forces of leftism and he said well there
are two ways to do it Michael you can
either persuade them or you can out
breed them and the latter is much more
fun a good at good advice you know we
got to be pro-life even if even if I
suppose we could win more elections if
we slaughtered all the lefties but I
don't think that'd be a good idea from
me either Michael a or Michelle I can't
tell which one that is how do you feel
the Bible addresses pacifism as a
conservative I have been very curious
about this because of passages like turn
the other cheek thank you for your time
and Veritas vos liberabit mmm I think
there were too many pacifists in the
church militant that's what I think
I think CS Lewis spelled this out very
well in an essay I think called why I'm
not a pacifist but one should turn the
other cheek of course this is a very
abused line of Scripture abused in
particular by the political left to turn
the other cheek is a as a an act of
moral defiance and moral dignity that
when some man
hits you or disrespect you or insults
you he degrades himself and he degrades
himself because you won't allow yourself
to be degraded you will allow your flesh
to be mortified and and for that
suffering to sanctify you this is not a
an instruction to let the cruel rape the
earth that's not what our Lord is
telling us to do so
ses Lewis spells it out in a few
different ways but if you a pacifism is
pretty self-defeating if in this sort of
lefty version of just be nice man I
forget there was a great theologian who
described most American churches and
most American sermons and homilies is
saying I would possibly suggest that you
try to be nice you know but in that if
you're supposed to love everybody and be
kind to everybody if person a is
attacking person B then to love person B
necessarily requires doing violence to
person a if you're going to have
pacifism peace on earth which isn't
going to happen anytime soon
then you need a whole whole nations of
pacifists the trouble is when you have a
nation of pacifists the barbarians come
in and and destroy them you know there
were as far the rudder so there are no
safe spaces when the barbarian invades
excuse me many other good arguments for
it you should check out CS Lewis's essay
on it it's a pretty good one and also
just be aware you know it's that
Chesterton line that heresy is not the
promotion of Vice it's the promotion of
virtue to the exclusion of all the
others one virtue to the exclusion of
all of the others so you might say oh
yes we should be really nice and meek
that's one that's one virtue but what
about prudence what about what about
judgment the exercise of judgment what
about you know not letting the cruel
rape the earth you've got to keep these
things in balance and there's nothing
there's nothing lovely or nice or kind
of compassionate about letting poor
innocent people be run over from Chris
good day from South Africa Michael I
know you are the conductor of the Trump
train choo choo my question is what
action of Trump would cause you to stop
supporting him well Chris I think at
this point if the president were to
shoot a man on Fifth Avenue he probably
still wouldn't lose my vote and I mean
that because he's been so good he's been
so good and I don't really care what
lefties think of me
I don't really care what P
like cocktail parties think of me I
don't care what fancy people who you
know read really old leather bound books
think of me I don't care what I care
about is the Liberty and I think some
people get especially disproportionately
people who are in the media conservative
and left they they're so afraid of
supporting Trump because they think
they'll be thought stupid or uneducated
or uncouth or you know not classy or not
whatever I'm not worried about that who
cares who cares what CNN thinks of you I
care about the Liberty and Trump is
doing a great job on that he's doing a
great job protecting life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and property is
standing up for the country so there are
very few things I mean I suppose if he
reversed his entire agenda that would
get me to not support him but I don't I
don't really see that coming he's been a
reliable conservative he's been much
more reliable as a conservative than are
perhaps some of our recent Republican
presidents which is maybe surprising but
the guy you know I don't put my trust in
Princes I don't put my faith in princes
so I don't really care if he reversed
his agenda tomorrow them okay I guess it
will turn on him but I
it doesn't bother me I think for some
people who don't like Trump or we're
never Trump or whatever they get they
take the presidency so personally they
say oh no it is I don't care the
president's not my Pope the president is
I don't worship the president I don't
identify with the president the
president is doing good things in his
job
as long as he's doing good things I
think that's great if he starts you know
being a big liberal Democrat we'll get a
new president
next question from Colleen Shapiro I
didn't take my question for the mailbag
this week so I'll have to settle for
store-brand Ben Thank You Colleen how
would you respond if a person called the
founding fathers terrorists all of the
Boston Tea Party I might be tutoring
some kids that this person teaches in
the coming school year what questions
could I ask the kids that would give
them an opportunity to form a different
opinion about our founding fathers
Thanks PS I secretly liked your show
don't tell anyone I won't tell anyone
tell Ben yeah I don't what should I tell
them I don't know the suggestion that
the founding fathers were terrorists is
asinine so I don't I wouldn't even
respond to it because it's so stupid
even the boy you're referring to the
Boston Tea Party is some
act of terror when we think of acts of
terror we think of violating the Geneva
Convention right targeting civilians in
acts of war torturing maiming killing
civilians what the American patriots did
at the Boston Tea Party is dress up like
Indians and throw some some tea in the
harbor not even that much tea how droll
what a what a funny little protest that
was that terrorism by the way the
Americans because it was a conservative
revolution they had a total respect for
decorum for law for behaving like a
gentleman for higher virtues for higher
principles one time General Washington
condemned a man of his own guard to
death because that man robbed some
people during the war he plundered some
people stole some things and he
condemned that man to death because he
would not be a terrorist he would not be
a villain or you know barbarian he was
going to fight like a gentleman because
he was a he was an upstanding man the
men who fought for the American
Revolution who won our freedom and won
our country were some of the most
upstanding men in all of history compare
them to us today compare them to our
culture today it's far degraded we would
be the barbarians but we would be more
likely to fit that category but no
there's no argument for that at all and
this is another one of these examples
I've been talking about it recently with
that XI Guevara you know Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes and she she Guevara you
know and she she doesn't know any she
it's not what she doesn't know that gets
her into trouble it's what she knows for
sure that just ain't so so when you see
this on campuses I saw this at Yale when
I was there that they instead of the old
math history English those liberal arts
would be pushed out a little bit and
what would start to take over were a
critical Studies departments which are
not they're not traditional liberal arts
they're just ideology basically so you
have winter women's gender and sexuality
studies ethnicity race and migration
studies and they were just ideology you
don't learn a lot of facts or details or
names or dates you just learn the
narrative and that's an example of that
someone might have this narrative this
ideological narrative that the founding
fathers were somehow terrorists
one question you could ask is what's an
example of that they'll be silent
next question from John how much more
time have one or two more I'll do one or
two tops that's it I promise from John
any man who voices approval at ariana
grande's art immediately forfeits the
right to criticize the manly sport of
soccer or to question the masculinity of
soccer fans fair point absolutely right
next question
from Sally dear Saint Michael
guardian-angel during last week's
mailbag someone asked about purgatory
and where they could find proof in the
Bible that purgatory existed you pointed
to mark 329 as a piece of evidence that
purgatory exists you said you didn't
have time in the episode to get into why
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit was
unforgivable but I was hoping you'd have
time in this episode to explain why
blasphemy against God or the Son of God
can be forgiven but why blasphemy
against the Holy Spirit is evil and
unforgiveable doesn't make sense to me
that blasphemy against two of the Holy
Trinity could be forgiven but why it
would be unforgivable to commit
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
especially since the Holy Trinity is
co-equal with one another thanks Sally
this is a tough question it's an
enigmatic verse in the Bible which is
when Christ says you'll be forgiven for
blasphemy against me or my father but
not against the Holy Spirit if you
blaspheme against the Holy Spirit that
will not be forgiven so why is that that
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
until you realize that it's it's true by
nature by nature that's the case there
are not limits to the mercy of God but
if you deliberately refuse to accept his
mercy by repenting then you're rejecting
the forgiveness of your sins and you're
rejecting salvation which is offered by
the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit if you
want to try to visualize it and this is
not an easy thing to do and certainly
you could never possibly do it perfectly
well there's a story of st. Augustine
trying to describe the Trinity and he's
walking along the beach and the little
kid is trying to shovel in all of the
water from the ocean into one little
hole Saint Agustin says you can't
possibly do that and then the legend
goes the boys transfigured into an angel
and he says yeah dummy and you can't
explain the Trinity is that okay that's
true but the way you can
sort of try to visualize the holy spirit
is that the Holy Spirit is the bond of
love between the father and the son so
you can even see this in Genesis in the
first moments of Genesis the act of
creation is an act of speech and God the
Father speaks the world into existence
and Christ is the word he's the logos
and you can almost visualize it as that
word is being spoken by the by God the
that bond of love that spirit that
breath the Hebrew word is Ruach is
breath or spirit is that bond of love
that proceeds from the father and the
son which is the bond of love between
them so if you reject that if you reject
that that advocate that Paraclete then
you're you are by definition rejecting
the forgiveness of your sins and that it
can't be forgiven because you you're
refusing forgiveness I hope that clears
it up a little bit okay we're we've run
two long enough of that I just figured
that's a good question to end on on a
show where half of the people talking or
wearing collars and or or rather
sophisticated and intelligent priests
okay that is the show I will see you on
Monday have a good weekend try to
survive listen to another kingdom
because we're getting ready for season
two of another Kingdom and it's going to
be a lot of fun so check it out in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knoll show I'll see on Monday
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018